christian javier and the right-hander is
making his seventh appearance sixth
start
yeah fastball's 91-95 with a slider
curveball and a changeup 26 strikeouts
and 25 and a 30. he does have good stuff
david fletcher will stand in for the
angels leading things off breaking ball
low and away did he go around he sure
did says first base umpire clint von
drake and fletcher is down on strikes
one away
two out of nobody on for mike trout and
that is strike three call at the top of
his own
trout and taking a step toward first but
home plate umpire chris guccione rings
him up trout has something to say about
it ending over
so they're runners at first and second
with one out for guriel that's grounded
softly third base side tough play suarez
bare hand stumbles throws
and it gets under cool holds his glove
and rolls down the right field line
altuve scores correa around third he
will score
as well and the astros lead two to
nothing on a ball that was hit maybe
60 feet on the third base side they
score
the two runners from first and second
josh reddick the batter
josh doesn't strike out much but he has
struck out his last four times against
his lefty
he doesn't strike out here line drive to
center field that will score
eule rbi single for redick he stays red
hot
as he is five for his last seven knocks
in run number three
so the astros have loaded the bases as
maldonado draws the free pass
and the table is set for jack mayfield
and he hits the ball hard to left field
that's down for a hit one run scores
reddick being waved around
upton's throw will not be in time two
rbi
single for super jack jack mayfield
makes it five nothing
and that is out number two as altuve
goes to third in correa in a second
so the next batter is taylor jones
that's a shot by the mound but
stopped by lestely bobbled it kicks it
up throws
and gets it to first base in time and
the inning will come to an end
when the angels have their first base
runner a two-out walk stepping up to the
plate will be david fletcher who struck
out his first time up today
wrecking ball that one's poked to left
field back goes tucker he's on the
warning track makes the catch right in
front of the out of town scoreboard
for the third out here's rendon two outs
no money off and he pops this one up
right near home plate maldonado drifts
toward third base
looks up and makes the catch for out
number three so
javier gets through the meat of the
order two three four
in perfect four so he's walked his first
batter
guriel's one for two singleton scored in
the first inning this one's ripped into
left center field that's going to split
the gap
here comes altuve around second trout
picks it up on the warning track they're
going to
send him altuve races for home and he'll
make it
a run scoring double by julie gauriel
and the astros lead six to nothing
so much fun to watch jose altuve flying
around the base paths
ariel such a slasher pitch down and away
drove it to left center field
trout getting to it on the warning track
no chance to get jose altuve racing home
javier yeah 23 year old dominican
right-hander not a lot of hit ohtani
moves up to second
jason castro will be the better lifted
into the air and it's going to fall into
shallow center field for a base hit that
is going to score ohtani the angels get
their first hit of the game with one out
here in the fifth inning
and first run so that puts a little bit
of a dent into the astro lead it's now
6-1 so two out castro still at first for
brian goodwin
this one down the right field line and
into the corner heading to
third base is jason castro he's going to
be waved around
reddick's throw is cut off and then sent
home
but scoring easily he's castro it's an
rbi double for brian goodwin and all of
a sudden it's 6-2
goody wasn't in the lineup yesterday and
he's been struggling but
he's had a walk in an rbi single in this
blog in fact goodwin came into
today's game one for his last 23 so he
needed something like that
tommy lestella will lead it off he's
gone over two this is the line out
toward left center field tucker move it
back and this one is gone into the
crawford boxes an opposite field
home run stella sneaks one over the wall
for his fourth of the season
hoping to say start me up but what's
tommy boy starts up this rally here now
in the sixth inning with a solo shot six
to three deficit now
seventh and final scheduled inning of
game one of today's double header astros
with a six to three lead over the angels
and ryan presley is on for the astros to
try and get the final three outs
presley one and one three saves and five
chances a five point eight seven era in
nine games seven and two thirds innings
eleven hits four walks
and nine strikeouts albert pujols will
lead it off that is sharply into right
field lead off single
continues to add on those hits all time
versus the ashford's third most all-time
coming of the game
back-to-back strikeouts for presley and
the angels are down to their final out
on the ground towards altuve yulia will
get back to the bag at this throw in
time to end the game
altuve to guriel to win it for the
astros
as they take game one of the
doubleheader by the final score of 6-3